Oscar nominated for his performance as
Muhammad Ali here is Will Smith
but since I'm here to present the Award
for Best Foreign Language Film I thought
that this might be a good time to say
hello to all the tens of millions of
millions of people watching around the
world so here we go
konnichiwa bonsoir Madame say Monsieur
me Primo famosa de las películas era
centro de philadelphia toronto me
vacaciones de navidad hey what happens
in Bangkok stays in Bangkok
now the Award for Best Foreign Language
Film the nominees are
Don't Tell from Italy Christina Comanche
knee
joyeux noël from France Christian
carrion
paradise now from the Palestinian
territories
Connie abu-assad sophie scholl the final
days from Germany
mark Rothman Tsotsi from South Africa
Gavin hood and the Oscar goes to so see
accepting the ward director Gavin hood
this is the first Academy Award and
second consecutive nomination for South
Africa with last year's nomination for
the film yesterday
Gazi sikelel iAfrika
god bless Africa Wow
I have a speech is in my pocket but that
thing says 38 seconds and mine's way too
long so got it sort see calm and there's
a huge long list of people because I'm
accepting this not for myself this is
for best foreign language film and
sitting right there to start with please
stand up Presley 28 a high and Terry
Peter my two fantastic young leads put
the cameras on him please
yeah Banga got cool you on for a two and
CC Bieber Africa Viva a my love I got a
10 seconds 10 seconds I just want to
thank my fellow nominees who I become
deep friends with we may have foreign
language films but our stories are the
same as your stories they are about the
human heart and emotion it says please
wrap thank you so much thank you the
Academy thank you
that was a great film by the way for
those of you who are keeping score at
home I just want to make something very
clear Martin Scorsese 0 Oscars three 6
mafia 1